[Applause]
all right we'll give stragglers your
second to grab their seats good evening
everyone before we begin
most of our usual housekeeping please
silence your cell phones and also we ask
that you refrain from any photography
both here and during the awesome book
signings is going to take place
immediately after this event in the main
lobby
welcome to the Free Library of
Philadelphia my name is jason freedman
and a cool part of this job is getting
to introduce writers that you like and
I'm excited to be here tonight to
introduce Sara Val praised by the New
York Times for her learned or learned
engagingly discursive funny sometimes
even jolly romps through American
history cultural critic sara val is a
clear-eyed funny eviscerating observer
of our history foibles and feats she is
the author of the partly-cloudy patriot
takes the cannoli
personal favorite assassination vacation
and unfamiliar fishes among other works
she was a contributing editor for this
American Life as well as one of the
original contributors to McSweeney's
she's also been published in a variety
of periodicals including the Village
Voice Esquire the Los Angeles Times and
too many others to name she has made
numerous appearances on Late Show with
David Letterman Late Night with Conan
O'Brien and The Daily Show with Jon
Stewart Sarah's new book offers a frank
portrait of the swashbuckling French
hero of the American Revolution and his
insightful return to our young country
interviewing stereo tonight is Wesley
Stace not only a frequent free library
guest author but also one of our
favorite interviewers of writers on this
stage I tried counting today's six seven
something like that times he's been here
he's the author of four critically
acclaimed novels including misfortune
Charles Jessel considered as a murderer
and most recently wonder kid
you may also know mr. States by his
rock-and-roll nom de plume John Wesley
Harding who has released
just 15 last time it's a gajillion
awesome smart fun folk rock albums wes
is also the founder of the cabinet of
wonders radio variety show which is
released a who's who I'm sorry which is
featured a who's who of contemporary
musicians writers comedians and other
sundry performers ladies and gentlemen
before you join me Sarah has said she's
going to read for a minute which is
terrific for us so now won't you join me
in welcoming Sarah Vowell and Wesley
space to the Free Library of
Philadelphia
hello Philadelphia um and I'd also you
know c-span is here typing so I'd also
like to say hello to the five insomniac
watching us at 5:00 a.m. on a Sunday I
just wanted to read a little bit first
because you can see what happens when I
can sit and think about what I want to
say and how I want to say it before I
sit over there and just jibber-jabber
willy-nilly
I'll just read one little excerpt from
the book I think the only thing and it's
toward the end so the only thing maybe
you would want to know is about how the
Marquis de Lafayette of our beloved
Revolutionary War hero from France who
came over in 1777 as a 19 year old and
was with Washington's army through
Yorktown in 1824 President Monroe
invited the elderly Lafayette on the eve
of the 50th anniversary of the
revolution to come back to America as
the nation's guest and it was quite a
to-do he will you remember what a big
deal it was in Philadelphia
and you know when he arrived in New York
Harbor eighty something thousand New
Yorkers were there to meet his ship and
the population of New York was I think
123 thousand so he has that on the Pope
most of the book is about his time in
the war and a little bit about that
return trip that this is I guess you
could call it a tangent nowadays La Fea
is a place not a person Lafayette is a
Boulevard in Phoenix a Pennsylvania
College and a bridge across the
Mississippi in Saint Paul
it's the Alabama birthplace of boxer Joe
Lewis and three different towns in
Wisconsin for if they account if so then
it is also Fayette County which the
chicken ranch better known as the best
little whorehouse in Texas put on the
map it is without question Lafayette
Indiana where the founders of both
c-span and Guns N'Roses were born when I
bumped into an old neighbor whilst
visiting my Montana hometown she asked
me what I was working on and I answered
a book about Lafayette
so she inquired if I would be spending a
lot of time in Louisiana and I was
confused wondering if she forgot that
Thomas Jefferson decided against his
initial impulse of appointing Lafayette
as the former French colonies first
governor after the Louisiana Purchase
but then I realized that the city of
Lafayette Louisiana must be heard go to
Lafayette labeled nouns
even though from Montana it's actually a
closer Drive to Lafayette Utah not to
mention the ones in Oregon California
Kansas and Colorado so I explained that
I meant Lafayette the French teenager
who crossed the Atlantic on his own dime
to volunteer to fight with George
Washington in the Revolutionary War
therefore I said I was more likely to
visit Pennsylvania where he got
I she nevertheless professed her
fondness for hai tujko this encounter
aroused such indignation in my breasts
that I moralized upon the instability of
human glory and the Evanescence of many
other things no way that's why herman
melville did in 1870 when a random
stranger in a cigar store had never
heard of his revolutionary war hero
grandfather when I found out my old
neighbor had never heard of my
Revolutionary War hero protagonist I
went and got a taco with my sister still
it does seem eerie how one day in 1824
two thirds of the population of New York
City was lining up to wave hello to
Lafayette and nineteen decades go by and
all that's left of his memory is the
name of a Cajun college town thanks to
the nationwide euphoria over the elderly
Lafayette's returned tour of the United
States in 1824 countless American
streets parks cities counties schools
warships horses and babies bear his name
the long list includes Scientology
founder lafayette ronald l ron hubbard
and my arkansas born great great uncle
lafayette Heinz who went by faith for
short the most meaningful namesake by
far is Lafayette Square across the
street from the White House also known
as Lafayette Park this is the nation's
capital of protests the place where we
the people gather to yell at our
president or as George HW Bush once
complained to Parade magazine during the
Gulf War he complained of the
demonstrators who were meeting those
damned drums in front of the White House
when I was trying to have dinner
while the rally Siddhant an act of civil
disobedience staged at Lafayette Square
over the decades I think we can agree
that the one Americans should be the
most proud of is the gathering of the Ku
Klux Klan there in 1982 the three dozen
or so stay with me the three dozen or so
white supremacist dunderheads who showed
up to demonstrate were provided police
protection against the hordes of
agitated counter protesters pouring into
the capital to demonstrate against their
demonstration freedom of expression
truly exists only when a society's most
repugnant nitwits are allowed to spew
their nonsense in public and in
Lafayette Park distasteful speech is
literally permitted with permits issued
by the National Park Service and a
federal agency managing the site it goes
on from there but you know you can read
that later come over yeah
oh oh you're holding it like Oprah or
something electro butt plugs hmm you
guys that you can just have yours
yes um don't tell me what to do whenever
so do you think when I would thing to
that laughs I it would you think of him
now despite all those things that are
named after him those towns and that the
glory that comes with that kind of lack
today same mm-hmm do you think of him
now as an obscure character and in a
sense was part of your point with the
book with like you know trying to let
people know about him um Wes is British
I don't know if you can tell he hated
the British well I was going to say many
historical figures in America are
obscure figures because we don't
remember anything you know so yes he's
obscure but I mean I guess many should
check with your teenagers if they know
who like Ben Franklin is or something
so is he an obscure figure he has to
become one I mean he used to be this he
I mean maybe was just the after-effects
from that trip in 1824 but I don't know
how many of you have been to the
Lafayette Monument in the Brandywine
Valley that is a little lamp look street
lamp lucky thing off the side of a road
but it's like Nowheresville in near West
Chester that sounds like a town right
and it's like in a lady's yard I met her
she was really nice and but when they
when they built that monument in 1895
after he had been dead for like 60 years
in 1895 five thousand people showed up
to celebrate this not very impressive no
offense monument being put up so I think
and then you know maybe the culmination
of the Lafayette legend comes in World
War one when you know France was in a
bit of a pickle and when the when the
American the Allied expeditionary forces
under general / she came to help out our
old allies the French against the
Germans they marched into Paris and they
marched straight to Pete Phu cemetery
where La Fea is buried and one of the
officers famously said Lafayette we are
here but after that you know people got
busy you knew here oh yeah
there was there was Hitler wolf yeah
yeah so I mean he in there he used to be
a bigger deal obviously and he's I'm not
one of those writers who I mean I've
certainly read some of these books where
you know where the writers like my
subject is so important if he had never
been born
there would have been a zombie
apocalypse you know I mean he was
important and certainly fascinating
enough but I mean I wasted three years
on him so he's up there but I mean in
the revolutionary generation is kind of
an embarrassment of riches you know
you've got your Washington your
Jefferson your beloved hometown boy
Franklin you know people are excited
about Alexander Hamilton these days
I mean maybe more partial to Henri nuts
the chief artillery officer you just
have well you know John Adam this one
about John Adams James Madison I mean
like it's I mean even I mean it's there
there's a lot of talent there you know
are you're going for knocks I mean he's
got to be the hipsters choice yeah I
mean certainly he is he's definitely the
writers choice because Henry Knox as you
know was famously a bookseller in Boston
the owner of the London book shop and he
joined up with the with a militia in
math in Massachusetts and eventually uh
you know when that marched into the
Continental Army he was the guy during
the siege of Boston who walked up he was
he was it I mean think about the guy you
buy your books from well I'm telling
this story hopefully it's still a guy or
a lady in a store yay
and so the book guy walks up to
Washington and I mean you know there's a
siege in Boston and the British control
the little Peninsula
of the City of Boston itself but they're
surrounded by all of these Patriot
militias that have kind of morphed into
the Continental Army and and they get
word that Ethan Allen and Benedict
Arnold who we still like at this point
have captured Fort Ticonderoga which
still has all these cannons and mortars
and howitzers left over from the French
and Indian War and and so in order to
break this stalemate they need not just
better weapons they need some weapons
and thinking about heavy artillery is
it's heavy and Henry Knox goes up to
Washington and he says my brother and I
will go get that stuff it's you know 300
miles away across the Berkshire
Mountains and it's winter and
Washington's like go ahead
and then you know a few weeks later here
is the knocks brother show up and think
about these special sleds and they'll
all I don't know how many hundreds of
tons of heavy artillery over the
BerkShares to Boston and then the crafty
Washington and and his men in the middle
of the night put them up on Dorchester
Heights and then the British down in
Boston wake up the next morning
impressed and they they leave my ships
to Canada never to return and so the
moral of that story is never
underestimate an independent bookseller
I know I know which side the bread is
buttered on okay well they're booked
we'll get back to all this laughs is
covering yeah um but but I have a couple
of questions one is it's just struck me
when you last year Quaker which is
possible in this town it's probable and
I'm I'm sorry that I was just glorifying
violet
mostly okay go ahead
that was a disclaimer let's come back to
the Quakers in a moment there's a lot
about place so just your description the
Quaker meeting will need to go to
exactly we should have one that'll be
great on c-span you should just do it
that it's like a whole room followed
people know that's what cue a nice good
like so one criticize I said anything
and it's just the sound of a bunch of
cheeses yes Dan Devon denim yeah and
that visuals will just be like people
look try not to make eye contact
title nobody moved well what you know
what you know you must do a lot of
obviously a lot of research on your
books there must be big fat books there
mm-hmm on your subject that you read
obviously and what you are doing as has
no I've dubbed you the hipster fits
story and I'm just going to keep going
with it now again robot well what you've
what you're doing is you know you're
taking the facts and you're taking the
urge to educate it it'll add the urge to
amuse people because you are you know a
comic writer also and you're taking your
love of the history and the first
question I want to ask is obviously it's
all an expression of you but in what
order do those things kind of topple out
of you when you you know first thought
of Lafayette yeah you're waiting for the
spark of an idea to come to you and then
when it does come how do you keep those
things in balance while you're doing it
because that's what we love about my
username timer no I literally like it
goes like I came gonna be educational
now Dave time for a jokey dope no I mean
those what you're talking about
the funny thing is is I mean I I called
them the books Republic and dads get for
Christmas
you know select single subjects book
about a person it's usually like the
title of the at the door stopper and
usually the title is like a person's
name and then you know when someone asks
them what's the book about and then
they'll say the person's name
they won't have this like weird word
like somewhat in their title but you're
just like oh my god that's going to take
45 minutes to unravel I always kind of
like in the beginning that's sort of
what I think I'm going to do write this
straight story and like what was last
minute
I had written a little short piece for
the Smurfs and life on public radio
about that return trip and it was very
sentimental and fizzy and it was all
about it was just kind of a love story
and about the American people's
affection for Lafayette and I just
thought I was to get to write this nice
book about this nice French boy and then
I don't know what I mean I never really
think these through enough I guess I
mean for one thing there's a war that he
said so that's no fun and then I mean
the reason I was drawn to him was
because I mean in 1824 the Civil War is
kind of like starting to bubble up you
know I mean basically it's now that I
think about it like the Civil War is
bubbling up you know across town in
Independence Hall in 1774 like right at
the beginning and so the thing like I
didn't dependence Holly you know the
First Continental Congress first thing
that happens the guy says we should
start with a prayer second motion is to
Episcopalian turning I'm saying no way
I'm not going to I'm paraphrasing I'm
going to pray with these Quakers and
Baptists and Congregationalists we can't
pray together we have too many religions
right there at the moment of you know
the official founding basically they're
all like we can't get along
I mean that may be the third thing that
should have happened was let's all go
home and save everyone the trouble so
anyway I was drawn to him because that's
because he because he was French Alessia
everyone loved him north/south
left-right he was just kind of this
other you know like everybody's uncle
from across the sea and I thought it
would be nice to write a sweet simple
story about this person everyone loved
and then in order to tell that story
pretty much at every step in the
research he gets here like I mean he's
here for maybe five months and he writes
George Washington a letter from across
the campus Valley Forge basically saying
I feel like America can defend it
herself like you can fight the British
if you would just stop fighting with
each other because all they do is bicker
the Congress can't get anything done we
disagree on everything the Congress and
the army are at odds there's a
conspiracy within the Congress in the
army to oust George Washington so George
Washington spends a few hours a day
fighting the British in a few hours a
day trying to keep his job from the
people who are undermining him his
friends and and then you know writing
about that trip in 1824 the 1824
election was in full swing when
Lafayette arrived it's it's the most
divisive presidential election in
American history there's no there's a
Andrew Jackson when it's a popular vote
but knowing when's the electoral college
and so it ends up being decided by the
House / the Constitution and but through
what comes to be known as the corrupt
bargain so everything is a mess and then
when I'm researching I just want to go
to my little battlefields to see where
my French boy got shot and it happened
to be in the fall of 2013 and the
government shutdown so Independence Hall
is closed
Yorktown battlefield closed and so looks
like
this all of this flame ended up
flavoring the story and if the book kind
of became two books maybe three if you
count the fact that I sort of use a
Lafayette as a personification of the
French Alliance in general so it's sort
of it's just expanded its waistline you
know it was going to be one of those
this happening doing this happened whom
many died but you know it's a lot of a
lot of your writing is dependent I met
some Quakers who distracted me anyway I
think you know a lot of your writing
obviously is you know dependent on your
personality it's filtered through you
and you're very much part of it you like
going to places you like telling us
about the people you meet yeah let's
went with me to one of the places Valley
Forge I did that's true that's true
we'll get moved on to that in a moment
but I can't tell you the inside stories
yeah there is um we had lunch and Dennis
teal that's true
I recommend the cucumber yes but but
what I want to do what go just going
back a little bit yeah I'm doing it to
you you have this like same questions
you are answered and I just keep like
interrupting you your television you
serve like tearing my hair tangents and
you know distracting you I want to take
you back to I want to imagine Sarah Val
at school and her relationship to
history what did that what happened but
now that this is what you right now
when do something must have I have two
images of me and American history class
one of them is me skipping it to go to
the public library to read and the other
one is sitting there with the boring
teacher at the blackboard and one kid
making a break for it and jumping out
the window and running away
I think like my my interest in history
and my kind of identification within in
fascination comes from my family
background and tell us more I mean you
know both of my parents have ancestors
who were Cherokee and were on the trail
of tears in the United States government
marched them at gunpoint to Oklahoma and
it was just a topic of conversation in
the family and then also at the chair to
the Capitol and in Tahlequah in Oklahoma
every summer when I was a kid we would
go there and watch they had one of those
amphitheater outdoor pageants so every
summer I was a kid I watch I mean it and
also I mean we we lived I had a very
rural childhood in there it was the only
theatre I ever saw you know till I was
maybe 14 or something so I literally
watched history come alive every summer
and this one story was so kind of
present in the family partly because um
my father was he hated Oklahoma and he
hated that he was born there and it was
Andrew Jackson's fault and you know the
historical tragedy made made it so that
he was born in this place he hated so
you know he had a bit of a bone to pick
with Andrew Jackson about that so I
think that this world is his own I call
sense now yeah so this world historical
event that had happened to mine I mean
it was in 1838 it's not really that long
ago that it happened to our not so
different distant ancestors that always
made history seem like something that
happened to people like us you know it
wasn't just this distant thing and I
don't think school really had much
bearing on any of that I think partly
because I was never one for textbooks
right I always wanted to read book books
and that's why I was skipping school all
the time to go to the public library but
I mean not you know not
not to psychoanalyze but what there's
such a clear line between you feeling
that your family was directly affected
by history and the kind of history that
you're writing for us nowadays of which
you are very very present in the writing
off yeah um yeah I mean I wasn't just
that - I think it was maybe just the way
my family was like it wasn't just that
story you know like the Civil War we had
my great-great-grandfather fought in
that and you know because the Cherokees
owned slaves he was I'm technically
eligible to be a member of the Daughters
of the Confederacy because the Cherokee
sided with the Confederacy so that was
just like you know my grandfather knew
that guy you know and then you know my
family's from Oklahoma and you know like
Pretty Boy Floyd left $20 under the
dinner plate when he like you know came
by and and Studebaker or whatever so
history just seemed like one of the
things you talked about is it was one of
the things that happened to actual
people I mean I missed that maybe
especially what's that Cherokee thing
like and with the Quakers - that I met
um you know they were incredibly well
informed about the Revolutionary War
like not only like most people I would
talk to had a like vague notion of who
Fe it was if they did it all and the
Quakers you know exactly who he was and
they had a problem with him and by
extension me you know and like we were
talking about that in one of the Quakers
said that sectarian groups tend to know
their history that quote actually kind
of left out at me when I was reading the
book and I found that when my last book
was on the United States takeover of
Hawaii in the 19th century and the
people who were the most educational for
me when I was researching that book were
the Native Hawaiian sovereignty as
give us the people who are still
protesting the American annexation of
Hawaii in 1898 and they they were I
learned so much from them
so and I'm not like one of it like one
program I think on TV where history
filters into a lot of the stories is the
family sitcom blackish you know and
where it's about this middle-class black
family and you know thing like there's a
whole episode about Martin Luther King
Day and how they go skiing on Martin
Luther King Day and how the different
generations are relating to these
stories you know or there was that whole
episode about the inward and I think
like history or there was one episode
recently about you know a family member
who was hesitant to visit a physician
and there was a whole thing about
Tuskegee and the experiments on black
people and it was basically like a
little documentary at the bidding so I
think people who come from who descend
from you know people who have been left
out or wronged in some way tend to be
very focused on history because they're
still upset about it you know and
usually for good reason and and so
you're one of the few Americans because
you're so engaged with history who
aren't envious at the fact that my
history in my country goes back so much
further you know I was IRA I was
speaking at the there's an American high
school in Paris and it's basically like
an international school I don't and I
remember this kid I was telling them
about what they do and that I write
about American history and this one kid
was like I don't understand that
there's only like 400 years of it like
like well a lot happened you know but I
think in like your history is my history
too
you know I am there I mean I've actually
spent a lot of time writing about how
British Americans are and that's not
necessarily a compliment so just to let
you know the well of my education a very
convenient place to start
English histories with the Tudors after
the war with roses and so when I went to
my first school that was where we
started and I did about the two years of
that and then when I was taken away from
that school for various reasons went to
another one started there again and then
when I went to the school of water and
food it all I know about its the Tudors
I did it three times in my you're
talking you Boudicca look her up
oh yeah well she yes she said she's cool
other day with the moment at the moment
when she stopped being called Boadicea
and started being called Boudicca that
was the big moment in her his wife's
whatever I mean I what about the boy
about on Magna Carta great prog band one
of my favorite so let's talk let's talk
about let's talk about writings of it I
recently had the pleasure to reviewed a
book for the tls a bunch of writing
about Hank Williams and a fantastic
piece by you that I quoted from in the
review that you wrote for someone in San
Francisco I presume about the Hank
Williams son boxer okay alignment in the
Village Voice yeah it was a wonderful
piece of writer but I think you know we
know you know this American life and and
your books and stuff but you know I
think you did you kind of start off as a
music writer maybe yeah it's pretty much
I mean I well I I am I used to be way
arts here and I studied art history in
school and then I started writing
actually for my college newspaper that's
how I started writing and I actually
started writing about visual art because
I just felt like the art reviews in the
Montana State University newspaper could
be better yeah
I decided I should give it a whirl and
then uh then I after school I wrote for
some art magazines a little bit and did
book reviews and then I moved into music
partly because of grill Marcus the music
writer he he was the woman I interviewed
him for my college paper and he kind of
got me my first job in journalism
writing for Art Forum and so through him
I mean he was like the only writer I had
ever met you know so I met a lot and I
had I had been a college radio DJ so I
had sort of a background in music so I
started writing record reviews and for
places like spin and then ready for
weekly newspapers and stuff about music
I mean mostly the first ten years as a
writer I would just I mean I would write
anything you know I would write I mean
it was like a record review a book
review column an interview radio
documentary I just did as much as I
could and I think that's great looking
back it's great for the experience
through so everything paid so poorly I
just had to do as much as I could and I
always had so many different interests
but yeah writing about music was um that
was I should remember though I mean I
was loved music but some sometimes I
think I was running out of adjectives
you know in record reviews and and also
I think I was becoming a nicer person
you know which made it harder to be a
critic like an honest critic I think I
got remember at one point toward the end
I was reviewing a flare record for spin
and it was obviously terrible but I felt
so bad and was saying that I just I was
like but the drums or mics really well
yeah
I had exactly the same experience
reviewing of the I've only reviewed one
novel and I'll never do it again well I
felt I couldn't be honest about the book
I felt too bad about doing I don't feel
so bad about nonfiction somehow through
the novelist well novelist I feel very
protected yes they're just little
delicate flowers and then these
nonfiction bullies they deserve respect
so what came first and off I mean you
know we know you can broadcasting we
know you from voiceovers we know you
from a string of books you know what was
the what was the thing that first took
off for you let's put it that way
oh that first took off well he took off
what about this American why would you
start working with this American like
what do you stop doing like it all
seemed like a progression at the time
this is making me sound like I've melted
multiple personality disorder now I mean
I I mean it's always like Wednesday so
like I started working on this American
life because I had met Ira Glass when I
was writing my first book which was a
diary of listening to the radio for a
year which is not a task I recommend
doing and I started writing that book
because I was 1990 was 19 June 1994 and
remember that midterm congressional
election that year and that was when the
ditto head caucus of those charmers took
over the Congress and they were calling
themselves that because they were very
proud to oh their allegiance to Rush
Limbaugh and they felt like this that
Rush Limbaugh and talk radio people like
him had you know won them this
revolutionary election and I had never
listened to Rush Limbaugh no one I knew
listen to Rush Limbaugh because I just
hanging out with namby-pamby people like
this you know and I just thought radio
is having this huge effect on the
country and no one was writing about it
there were no like radio critics and
newspapers the way other arts or media
are covered and so I thought
I wanted to write about this so I just
started I just turned on the radio and
started listening I heard some really
dispiriting things but but and then
because I was writing that book and then
I had moved to Chicago to go to school
and I met Ira Glass and then you know
then I had just become friends with him
and I was writing for one of the local
papers in Chicago and I was having
dinner with IRA and I told him I I had
written a book review about a record
guide a book of you know music reference
book and I had gotten a thank you letter
from this random guy in Chicago thanking
me because I had mentioned a Fastback a
great old Seattle punk band goose you
know them and this guy thanks to me for
mentioning them just a guy he wasn't in
the band and then he closed in his
thank-you letter this book he had made I
mean this was sort of I guess maybe Al
Gore had invented the internet by that
point but normal people didn't have
access to it so now we're used to
because of the internet were used to all
the many splendored corners of obsession
in the world and its expression by
random people in their basements but at
the time I had since his book he had
written that was all about the fastbacks
with all these pie charts and you know
as you know the fast X went through a
lot of drummers and women turbos any of
there were these charts about like rusty
played on 15% of the song yeah Mike's my
quest burger you know and I'm watching
Guns and Roses
yeah the drummer that's right decima
Kagan or the first drummer the fast fact
he was in there sure this is good stuff
c-span yeah wait for wait like wait till
we bring up Kurt oh hello welcome
oh my god Kurt black that guy should run
for president he's the guitar player I'm
so frightened and Tommy yeah anyway I
was just kind of knew his IRA and it's
like you can't believe this letter I got
any it's like I was asked a lives in
Chicago he's like I'll just I'll give
you a tape recorder
it wasn't even would you like to work
for my radio show I was just like are
giving you a tape-recorded that was the
whole conversation
it was just like of course you're going
to go to this guy's apartment and talk
to him about his obsession you know and
that's how bad that's not was a priest
was it that was my first piece oh my
goodness I'd love to hear no it's
probably on the internet now
I don't have that yeah so anyway I was
like things always you know and that was
I guess he could say that came out of me
working for that paper writing reviews
I'm very spirited working on that show
and doing more stories and then and then
I made a documentary on I need to keep
bringing this up the Trail of Tears and
that changed my life because that was
the first like American history story I
had done and I loved it I mean I loved I
mean it was hard because a lot of people
died in the story that was the personal
connection yeah but what's the personal
connection but I mean it's interesting
like that story I I was doing what I was
going to be doing the rest of my life
right away which was it was a road trip
it was it was a documentary of driving
the whole trail with my twin sister and
so we went to places along the way and
it was kind of it turned out I mean
basically what I've always been writing
about is America and American culture in
some form or another whether I was
writing about Hank Williams or writing
about you know New England missionaries
to Hawaii or whatever and that trip it
was a team you mean like the perfect way
to talk about not just American history
but America itself because it was a road
trip so it would stop and you know we
were crying every day because every time
we would stop it would be like where
more people were buried along the way
like 4,000 people died along that trip
which was about a fourth of the tribe so
everywhere every day we would drive
would stop we would stand
I mean sometimes there were little old
graves and cry and then because it was a
road trip we would go get barbecue or no
or we would listen to Chuck Berry or at
one point you know going to Chattanooga
which was one of the starting points for
like the Trail of Tears doesn't start in
one place that just starts wherever
Cherokee were living and they were
kicked out from there and some of them
were in Chattanooga and there we stayed
at the Chattanooga to to
and it was like really fun to say to
chew all day long so we were having this
like we would cry and then it would be a
fun mention and it all made like later
on
I remember reading what the novelist
Steve Erickson
I think wrote that the two great
inventions of America are annihilation
and fun I mean he was because he was
writing about the nuclear test in the
Nevada desert in Vegas you know I'm so
like on that trip it would be like
Indian genocide barbecue you know racism
watching the x-files with my sister in a
motel room you know so like the whole
thing seemed because this country is
both of those things its annihilation
and fun you know so I think like it's
such an extreme place well on the book
and the new books of a good example of
that too isn't it because a lot of the
things you're doing are some things to
be doing well yet what we would fly they
were doing when we were all well you
know what we were doing when we were on
the Valley Forge site because we were in
a place that where there have been
incredible devastation and deprivation
and we saw that is some movie about
everything
that they show at the Valley Forge
battles like some of you might have seen
it and yet we were having quite
enjoyable time uh-huh yeah because I
mean yes I didn't really know what we
were looking at so you were able to
explain it all to you that's that worked
out well yeah so I mean one reason I
invited wet because you know he's
British
and I thought oh this will be fun to be
with a British person and just like rub
it in all day
but as it turned out like he like knew
nothing about the revolution order
because they don't care about it they
don't learn nothing we want to know
about it here's the [ __ ] I think it just
it was just like a colony that was a
loft yeah so he robbed me of what was
supposed to be my greatest fun of the
day if you'd only alerted me to I could
have acted it a lot yeah I need to
remember there's that big monument at
Valley Forge with all the names of all
the you know generals like Lafayette and
stipend and Oda Cal the kelly green and
and um we were talking about later and
with those are people you know and what
feels like you know that big monument
thing without the Brooklyn streets I
know what I'm talking about yeah yeah it
was like we just focused on the warrants
we won which were a lot of those well
some with your help now something says
actually a very funny thing so you know
what
sighing that typically is it Lafayette
on that I am that's good right
I mean I say Lafayette and unless I'm
saying walkway it kind of like you know
that tongue um I was dancing in the
lesbian bar yes version eight says both
less a fair and blase fair does he in
the same film looks very I like that I
think ok well because of the gallery it
could be here they do wrong I can get
the Galeries Lafayette
yeah the gallery cuz he's got that whole
shopping thing named after him in Paris
yeah I don't think he got any of the
backend um well maybe his family did
somebody is it very good quick so he was
French he came over some time sitting in
their underwear like I just wanted to
watch c-span like real peace fans
I think they're getting their money's
worth when they read the culture
references from Jonathan Richmond to the
fastbacks have been so why bring
solitaire maybe we'll only rock covered
yeah but last by it was a Frenchman who
came over to America to fight a war
against the British right and somebody
says very cleverly in your book so
you're writing about a Frenchman who got
muddled up in a war on a continent far
away from where he was from against the
country very close to where he was from
it's like somebody from Ukraine battling
Russia in Brazil okay was that you what
did you say that oh it is me actually
yes sorry good yes I mean one reason one
reason Thanks salad I love it when
people quote them so you know what what
can you be honest about that yeah I
don't think I said that I think you
improved whatever I say no you said that
I'd say that see how to I said to my
friend when you read this bit of the
book I think there's one bit that
doesn't sound like me it sounds too good
for me that they're talking about
Ukraine in Brazil I'm not sure I know
where those places are do we need to
compliment you further
it's all about you yeah it's all about
me so what we would like to do I mean we
I could go on talking to you for hours
but what we should do hmm because of the
signaling that I see so frantically
occurring is to take some you know
what's easily it's like winter black
plays the guitar jumping up and down yes
that's right well they're what we need
that what we need you to do because if
you would like you're quick you'd like
to ask there a question please do so if
you would like that question to be heard
on the podcast or on on the television
then please wait until the microphone
gets to you even if you think you can
shout loud enough so does anybody have a
question for Sarah there's one right
there that gentleman there the
microphone is coming towards him now I
would like to thank Wes and also say he
really did prepare questions about the
actual book and I kind of kept just be
railing you liked it well I just like to
ask one good question at the beginning
and then have a chance yeah I think
that's what the people I mean why are
they gonna do fire nothing's worse than
a question master with an agenda yeah my
only agenda is keeping you talking
because it's so entertaining let's have
a question I feel I'm thinking all day
what question I wanted to ask Sarah Val
is in when you're gonna marry
why'd you come up with so when you went
on the Trail of Tears grand tour are you
ever going to get over that no well when
you wrote about it in your book you know
what I think of when I see the $20 bill
I think I know where you're going with
this I'm talking about you know putting
a woman on the $10 bill but leaving the
$20 bill alone so I'm wondering first
what did you think when you heard that
news and who do you think should be on
either of those two bills hmm
I mean yeah like a the $10 bill as I
recall they're not going to come they're
not going to completely get Jamison
right one of the proposals is there will
be two or there will be two pictures on
it or there would be two separate $10
bills I don't know but yeah why the 10y
Hamilton you know everybody loves a
Treasury secretary but like they Andrew
Jackson one I mean people are talking
about it and I would I mean I would love
for I would love to get rid of him on
the 20 because it's really distracting
you know like say you're just say you
have the afternoon off and you and your
sister are like going to go see the new
Tom Cruise movie and you've got your
popcorn you're paying for it and then
you have to look at the face of the guys
whose policy you know ruined your
ancestors alive like puts a damper on
things right so I mean if they want a
woman I mean it well I'm not I mean I'm
not completely opposed to everything
about Jackson but there's just something
I mean I'm against nullification like
everyone else here but uh you know um
what was able to say uh if you work and
have someone all right he might be like
to have well I grew up in Montana and
are great you know heroine in Montana's
Jeanette Rankin I think her her name
thing bandied about she's the first um
she's the first female Congress person
and she looked - really - yeah and she
is she's the only member of Congress who
voted against entry into World War one
and World War two and even though I
think most people in Montana mmm I would
say most people are kind of on board
with World War two everyone when I was
growing up there everyone was always so
proud that she voted her conscience you
know and then when I was a teenager in
the 80s in the anti-nuclear movement you
know she was like our great hero because
she had been like she had just been a
great peace activist her entire life up
through the Vietnam War there's a statue
of her in my hometown she's one of the
great heroes of Montana and whether you
agree with how she voted or not she held
her ground and it was not popular stance
you know especially with World War two
so she is I think a person of character
and quality and you know I wouldn't mind
looking at her when I was buying
two-year mints or something there was
another question right back the yes
okay it comes to my crew um so I haven't
had a chance to read your book yet but
that's okay just came out yesterday what
were you doing last night
I'm sorry I was studying for two I know
I did buy it but I wasn't okay oh I was
wondering um did you take the test yet
yes how did you do I got a oh well then
I was worth it so I studied a early
American history Revolutionary War and I
was wondering if there's anything when
you're reading the correspondence
between as they were lovingly called the
gay trio the John Lawrence Alexander
Hamilton and Lafayette I was wondering
if there was anything that you read that
was like really like a lot of the
frequency up is kind of left out a lot
of the history books linked biographies
I know there's just so focused on
accomplishments and achievements and not
who was making out yeah so as well as
learnings there was anything well I
remember when we were at Valley Forge
and we asked the Ranger like remember we
asked there's that house that Washington
stayed in and that also Hamilton and
Lawrence were staying in and we asked
him and he didn't really want to talk
about that no he was quite over by that
I know I mean I did it
are you writing is that what you mean
about their their alleged affection for
one another I mean no I didn't come
across any new groundbreaking evidence
of that would probably be pretty
disgusting some physical evidence of no
I'm stretching by this point put that
under 20 so now I didn't I mean I just
spend more I just spend a little bit of
time they been because he is so
important to the actual story and
because he's the one who reshaped the
Continental Army into a more or less
effective fighting force and the whole
reason he came here was because he was
out of a job and and there were there
were those like gay rumors about him
that he had taken liberty with young
boys in Prussia and so he was out of a
job and because um because Europe was at
peace for a little bit longer all the
you know every professional soldier in
Europe was scrambling for work and
because he had this rumor hanging over
his head and he was broke that's why he
came here and he didn't have he didn't
have a commission when he left Europe he
just came here like hoping you know to
get hired and hoping that rumor didn't
follow him here and I don't know there's
no right as far as I know there's no
conclusive evidence one way or the other
I know the Advocate refers to him as a
confirmed bachelor and I mean it's
possible maybe it's even probable he was
a homosexual and Randy Shilts writes in
his book about gays and lesbians in the
military that is possible when French
turban arrived at Valley Forge that he
witnessed the first soldier be dismissed
from from the American military for
homosexuality a guy who was literally
literally drummed out of the camp like
with drums and stuff so I don't I I
don't know about Lorenz and Hamilton
they're there I read some of those
letters and they are very affectionate I
mean they are you know in a war together
and very good friends who knows but a
bunch driven it's very possible and that
was you know basically the reason he
came here whether he was gay or not
so I mean certainly like up through past
the don't-ask don't-tell era his was a
really important story especially to gay
and lesbian soldiers you know because I
mean so many of his his his drill manual
you know that he wrote was officially
part of the US Army until the war of
1812 but much of what's in the Army's
drill manual today carries over from him
and so his ideas about you know military
order and discipline and you know
training exercises and stuff work have
been part of the American military
tradition from the get-go
so if you know gay and lesbian soldiers
were being excluded that is pretty
hypocritical you know so I don't know
but what Tim it seems I don't know it
definitely is possible maybe it's
probable but about the other guys I'm
not sure that's a question on the end of
the road right there so earlier you
mentioned this monument that was located
somewhere locally regarding walk I had
this lamppost and one of the fascinating
things about your book is you look for
these off the beaten path for lack of a
better term landmarks and then someone
who took road trips as a kid I can
relate to that very much so do you have
a story about what you consider to be
the strangest of these landmarks you've
ever encountered whether for research
for one of your books or through your
own travels the strangest I mean some of
it I don't know about strangest but some
of the most perplexing or well I
remember going to the McKinley memorial
in Canton Ohio and you know I mean he
was an assassin ated president and I do
remember that in the gift shop of the
McKinley Memorial the souvenir was a
yo-yo
so it's this incredibly you know
doh stone edifice to Ohio's assassinated
president one of them and that was the
that was the memento was a yo-yo
I found that a little disrespectful I
mean probably the most disturbing to me
was when I was writing that book about
assassinations and coming across the
memorial to John Wilkes Booth in
Virginia that's sort of in this like
highway median in Virginia it's a really
spooky and very reverential and kind of
a memorial to him it's not official
it looks pretty fishy but some people
it's there and that I found pretty
creepy
but meaning like light-hearted uh
I mean honestly
and my hometown one of the founders of
the town his name was Nelson's story and
he he was he became the richest man in
the Gallatin Valley and partly because
he started out he had this cattle drive
from Texas to Montana he I think the
person Lonesome Dove is based on and
like I grew up on story street and then
his son or his grandson I can't remember
was still alive up until a few years ago
and you know he he he was this guy's
just like shuffling around town his name
is Malcolm he's very nice man just kind
of walking around town in his plaid coat
and everybody knew him everybody and
their dogs and then when he finally died
the town put up because he had just
lived till well into his 90s you know in
the town put up a monument to him that
was on the old property of the old story
mansion which is became the middle
school that I went to and was also had
been the high school before that and
like the high school where Gary Cooper
went to high school and was on the
grounds of the old story mentioned and
so they put up this
to have malcolm in like in his plaid
coat you know and when that statue went
up my sister's dog went bananas for it
you know because she remembered Malcolm
you know and so everything cuz Malcolm
was always walking around town and so is
Lucy the dog you know and so it's so
weird when Lucy seems like the statue
Malcolm you know but I really like that
that the town just put up this monument
to a guy everybody knew because it was
really old and we all grew up saying hi
Malcolm penis I don't know who put up
that statue but it's still it's still
there we are going we are only able to
have I'm afraid one more question
I'm sure you will after that join with
me and thank you Sarah
again whoever's got the hand up there we
go who the pressures on you man there's
a question about the two revolutions
that object was involved in is it true
that Jefferson was not entirely
satisfied with his Declaration of
Independence and so when he was
ambassador to france in 1788 and 89 he
and jefferson together wrote he in
lafayette together wrote the french
Declaration of Human Rights the Rights
of Man in a bunch of moments they wrote
a draft of it they wrote a draft of it
and together and then it was edited much
like the Declaration of Independence was
from Jefferson didn't you have some but
you want to give that guy the microphone
he seems to have something to say about
this was Tom Paine
friends right butcher that the
Declaration of Rights of the Man of Man
and of the citizen
I mean various people contributed to
that but it was Lafayette and Jefferson
who wrote one of the draft later
gentlemen should we take one more
question I think that'll be fantastic I
think one more question would be a
fantastic idea to somebody right in the
front who's so near to us but still
we're going to wait for the microphone
thank you so much
you kind of touched on it early but I
really enjoy books by yourself in Tony
Horwitz because you guys meet everyday
people and write so fondly about them be
it just a normal shop worker or somebody
who's a tour guide you ever have meet
somebody who's reluctant to take part in
the book or somebody that needs prodding
or do you find that most people are
eager to share their thoughts with you
um no it's usually the opposite I mean I
find there's there's so much especially
like local knowledge is so helpful to me
and I mean it was that way when I was a
reporter writing about anything I when I
was running out the Oneida community and
you know which is a 19th century
biblical vegetarian sex cult and I think
I had maybe written them off a little
bit I mean there are a lot of things
about it's where their community is
where the term free love comes from and
there are some eccentricities about
their living arrangements and I think I
was I had a lot of condescending
feelings toward them and it just seemed
too bizarre and I wasn't really thinking
about these people as people I was there
because president Garfield's assassin
had lived among them for a while and I
wanted to see where they had lived and
and I mean this place became it was one
of those you know utopian communities
from the burned-over district in upstate
New York and I was taking
the tour from a retired high school
American history teacher who was a
docent there and he was talking to me
about them and he said I've spent so
much time you know is the mansion house
where they all lived he said I spent so
much time here thinking about these
people and why they would come here and
I mean one of the things one of the
reasons they came there was because they
had this idea that God had made them
perfect and they should move upstate and
sleep around I don't know but but he he
said he kept thinking like why would
they come here why the would they do
this I mean it was you know they would
cut was like by 1830s and 40s and they
were coming there and and they had
practice groups marriage and it was very
eccentric for the time and would be now
you know and I mean I just basically
kind of thought of it as like living in
a big house with all of my weirdest
college roommates here and and he said
he kept thinking about them why they
would do this and then he was reading
Jonathan Edwards reading centers in the
hands of an angry god and it's I mean
it's a great sermon but it's pretty
harsh and terrifying and you know that
like human beings are the sinners but
like God is dangling over the fire and
how rigid of a way of thinking about God
was and and how rigid the lives of the
people who listening to such sermons and
you know that form of Protestantism and
Christianity and he said he thought like
what if you were one of these people and
these are the kind of sermons you're
listening to and there was this place
here where you could breathe and you
could think of yourself not as an ugly
depraved sinner you know but you could
think of yourself as a free person with
the value
we'll and it really changed how I
thought about these people you know and
their ambitions for their own lives and
to find this place that seems so crazy
and silly to me and there are some
disturbing things about it but just that
it was this place of refuge and freedom
and community and you know he really
made them seem like someone I would know
because the context is very important
yeah and other weird things seem from a
distance yeah well I mean there's um
there's so much there there's so much
knowledge out there and I think it comes
back to what I was talking about about
learning history maybe not necessarily
always in class like that history comes
from for me like talking to my
grandfather or my father or my uncles or
you know people like that there I'm
obviously a writer and I'm in favor of
you know literacy and the written
tradition but there's something to be
said for you know passing down knowledge
verbally and meaning meeting your fellow
citizens you know it when you ain't
going I was never in history when I was
in the Brandywine Valley talking to
those Quakers who really were not
excited about the idea of another war
book coming into the world you know I
was thinking I mean so much in my book
is about the discord in American life
and the only time we hear about these
disagreements especially in the media is
like when our Congress shuts down the
government or something or when people
show up at military funerals to protest
and you know all of these fights about
abortion and stuff like that but when I
was sitting in that meeting house in the
Brandywine Valley talking to these
friends
and we were you know laughing and joking
and talking they were telling me you
know not just saying like we're against
war but they were explaining like
everything the people in that valley
went through because of the war you know
that their crops were taken by both
sides by both armies their stuff was
stolen it was like a real hardship for
the people of the place that it's not
just their like against war in the
abstract there are real reasons to
question the sanity of war you know and
even though obviously didn't give up on
my quest to write about this warrior
just the idea that we were like having
this very pleasant civil conversation
with you know mild disagreements like
that to me is that kind of stuff
you never hear no one's going to write a
newspaper article about that you know
but people can live amongst each other
and learn from one another and you know
sometimes disagreements can be
educational and even though you know I
don't walk that Quaker walk I think or
you know I think the book maybe walks a
little differently because I met them
and so it's one thing I mean there are
things to be learned from archives and
records and old letters and I use all of
that but also just you know talking to
other people who have thought about
these things is really I think important
and useful and also Pleasant
as this talk has been thank you so much
she will hold on a second tonight she
will be upset of course signing her book
on behalf of the Free Library of
Philadelphia I'd like to thank very much
and will you join me in thanking Sarah
foul
[Applause]